[Music]
Jeff and gain the traffic king and queen
are back baby the much anticipated
Epstein file has dropped it's 1,000
Pages only Cat Williams can read that
fast so here are the hits turns out the
Epstein Island conspiracy is some fresh
blood and no I'm not talking about Hyman
human Hot Wheels Steven Hawking got
rolled into this kid diddling debacle
Hawking who apparently loves strip clubs
and looked like he got a lap dance from
a wrecking ball visited Epstein's Island
for an academic conference in 2006 where
he was rumored to have an underage orgy
or as he calls it the Gang Bang Theory
Epstein tried to pay people to discredit
the rumor and cover up Hawkings tire
tracks They even tried to erase Steven's
memory by shaking him like an ETA sketch
Hawking wasn't the only new name
revealed voice actor for a cartoon dirt
bike RFK Jr was on the list he
immediately blamed his ex-wife for being
on Epstein's plane and at his house
finally a Kennedy that knows how to use
his wife for cover Honestly though does
the CIA kill everyone this guy knows
look I just hope he wasn't at the Steven
Hawking orgy okay the kennedies have
seen enough brain splatter think about
it David Copperfield also was allegedly
at Epstein's house because when there's
kids to entertain you hire a magician
they actually asked Copperfield if he
wanted a 26-year-old to which he
responded in true magician fashion let's
cut that in half aside from those guys
it's just the same CTIC characters that
deserve to take a submarine trip to the
Titanic Bill Clinton was mentioned but
the worst thing they said about Bill in
the whole drop is he likes him young I
mean this guy is slipperier than Stephen
Hawkins chin as of now the only miners
that we know for sure Clinton [__]
were the ones digging out of the rubble
in Haiti and you can't mention Epstein
without his favorite royal kid Rin
prince Andrew I mean how is this guy not
in jail oh yeah he's a [__] Prince I
can't believe England pays for this guy
to fly around the world and [__] teens
at least in America we elect people to
fly around the world and [__] teens the
royal family claims that what prince
Andrew is doing is not grooming it's air
conditioning now if that joke is
confusing try spelling air h e i r
ultimately this drop was more useless
than Steven Hawkings Fitbit the
allegations are so old Clinton wouldn't
stuff is cocking him hopefully more
information comes out hopefully Justice
is served and hopefully Epstein and
gilain or jiz lane or whoever the hell
you pronounce her name hopefully they
both rot in hell I mean that would be a
mad with a happy ending now let's start
the show all right so how y'all how
y'all feel about um uh the hawk how you
feel about the hawk dude young hackey yo
young hawky the hackey talky yo the h
is that what you call yeah so what what
what do you guys think about this so I
when I first saw the thing that he was
watching midgets do uh equations on the
board oh yeah I was so excited yeah that
was the best uh that was a a Twitter
setup yeah not real huh yeah not real at
all but yeah what was the allegation
[__] I really wanted to believe that
yeah I know I know I know so the
allegation was that he used to watch
midgets naked midgets do algebra
problems on a chalkboard that was too
high for which not illegal yeah not
illegal at all that scenario is [__]
it's it's such a good lie whoever came
up with that somehow stepen Hawkin has
become more likable through this right
like the idea that he was on this island
somehow like rolling around in the sand
yeah not wheelchair accessible but he
figured it out yeah taking place in
these like underage orgies it's like
which is wrong but there's no way that
he could communicate he wanted
it what do you mean like he could be
like I don't that was a computer they
were typing [__] in got hacked I got
hacked he got hacked pedophile pedophile
pedophile Jeffrey Epstein was on the
[__] uh on the keyboard I was
disgusted you could see it on my face I
was like this poor
[__] but unfortunately I had to do it
yo cuz my AI wanted to get crazy that
being said he has a little reputation of
being a wild boy cheating on your wife
while you're that crippled was he that
crippled at the time he cheated yo maybe
he was raped son okay I don't know low
key like we always put on Stephen
Hawking because we hate men yeah you
know what I mean cuz women hate men yeah
exactly of we're living in a matriarchy
so immediately assume a man who's
crippled and can't even move his
eyebrows he literally communicates with
blinking MH that he has the capability
to not only have sex with another woman
seduce another woman no he can't give
consent he literally can't come on he
literally can't yeah this [__]
been getting raped they've been rolling
him around the world from rape to rape
he's been trafficked he is is the
traffic bro he he's he's the traffic
he's he needs an apology from Virginia
goofy he needs an apology from soy Berg
or whoever the other girl he needs an
apology for every girl on that list why'
y'all didd Stephen Hawkins he didn't
want to [__] y'all he want to do science
experiments that's all he wants and they
rolling him into the strip club this
mutant and forcing him to do this [__]
that he don't even want to do in cargo
probably in you're not you're not was in
first class you put him in the overhead
I put him under the sea in front of me
victim he got a good hit list though he
got a pretty good hit list for victim he
knew though he knew he knew and he was
hitting for a while I mean how old did
he get oh wait what do you mean like how
old did he live to like usually they go
sooner if you got that if you got fold
him up into luggage disease then then
they usually go if you have a way back
syndrome you do get you do die slightly
early he does fold up he is he he went
to 76 no [__] way yeah oh that's a
good 76 right there anyway my point is I
think that I think that stepen Hawking
deserves an apology one from Twitter mhm
right assuming that he would want to do
something so silly is to watch [__] do
math problems on a chalkboard it was too
high for them on their tippy toes also
if it's too high for the [__] it's
probably too high for him also also
[__] on their tippy toes is mad
funny get on your tippy toes just to
turn a doorknob get on your tippy toes
to hit a light you saw the raccoons
trying to open the open the door no oh
man this is far I love all the people
that just sent me [__] [__] bro they
know that's your [__] now yeah they know
are you to midgets now son they're just
funny
people I mean they are they are a funny
group of people and now they're leaning
into it too so it's like now they're
like making Tik toks and [__] oh come on
now that's what it looked like when they
were trying to do the math problem come
on come on now I think I don't know this
is this is a artistic interpretation
come on now the me that Stephen Hawkins
should have been crazy isn't it wild
like is something as absolutely vile and
disgusting as uh you know sexual assault
and if you add Stephen Hawking into it
it it there is some levity yeah it comes
real funny it's not funny no no no it's
not funny what them girls did to
him it's not funny yeah it's disgusting
what they [__] did M I believe in
victims I don't know I mean it's
discussing what happened to those girls
with other guys yeah that's [__] up
but what heard people heard people
clearly they were like oh I'm going get
my get back I got this jellyfish looking
[__] over there yeah unplug the
scooter he's not going anywhere sit your
ass oh you ain't moving no back it up
T I got your
fireworks damn okay so Stephen Hawkin
but besides Steph Hawkin the [__] was I
mean pretty much everything we knew
cober field was also fire yo cober field
was wild so David Copperfield obviously
magician we talked about him in the rant
but like apparently he was at the house
and just to put in context with all
these things so these are court court
documents that have been leaked so a lot
of these things are allegations about
people so it's not like hey we have
proof that this thing happened somebody
is accusing or alleging that this person
did it so with Sten Hawking basically
the way that they get him to the island
is in 2006 he was he was at the island
for this academic conference so I guess
there's a bunch of other academics there
and now to be fair in 2005 Epstein was
accused of uh sex trafficking yeah but
he wasn't convicted he wasn't convicted
I think in 2008 so but still like once
they put that on you that's the first
bit did in Florida 2008 he does the bid
okay 2005 he gets accused 2006 the
academic conference happens I'm just
saying if a dude who allegedly raped an
underage girl invites me to his Island
while there's an open case I'm going
wait until the verdict do you know what
I mean yeah are we really researching
everybody we run into
though but you should know if you're
going is I think I I think we just
researched it's wire fraud you know what
I mean it's like to be fair let's just
call it what it is before we knew all
this about Epstein
right it kind of was the place to
be and what date what date meaning
meaning everybody was there what year
the president's there not Michael
Jackson's there yeah RFK Jr's there like
everybody's there the parties are crazy
like there's a lot of people that went
to epsi and [__] back in the day that
are quiet right now like oh man I didn't
know he was out here I just thought it
was the party to be at mhm so the if the
president goes to a place where did we
go eat on the road Al when we were on
the road together where did we go eat
every single City not
St but we went where what Obama's
favorite spot we went where the
president went it can't be bad you know
Lo behold all those spots are rapers
probably by the same logic you brought
to a bunch of barbecue joints Obama was
never on the he
wasn't he wasn't what I'm saying is
maybe they were owned by that that's
traffic free food right there
soe food yeah all I'm trying to say is
you never know you do never know yeah
but Copperfield was there the whole
transcript is so funny with him because
they're like he was doing magic tricks
then he leaned over and he was like do
you know that girls are trying to get
other girls and that's like the whole
thing that he's in the transcript for
and I was like why would he bring that
up after doing a magic trick I mean cuz
he knows why He's there cuz he knows
some other [__] is going on yeah I was
happy there was very little black people
on this list come on they were happy
also y weren't invited I who was who are
the black people on the list you make it
sound y make it sound like y'all aren
pedophiles now y'all just weren't in the
in the circle yeah you're not cool
enough what you mean we got our Kelly we
uh well Mike was there but he was white
we wait at the time that's what I'm
saying we be snitching y we be snitching
oning y'all be bragging that's your
problem we can't take you to some fun
[__] and then you're not
tell about 20 bad [__]
on no I didn't know where I got this
from where the second I experienced some
cool [__] I got to tell everybody but
it's literally just grown up with black
people yeah white people like to hold
[__] to themselves and be secret is
there another group of people that do
that oh brid and tunnel
[Laughter]
folks send them back it's
okay I love that we're going to talk
about the Jews in their tunnel now yeah
Tanya had a funny comment she was like
yo this is worst time for Jews to be
caught building tunnels bro it's insane
yeah you were accusing Hamas of tunnels
this whole time also I saw I said to
y'all this video we should put the play
the video but they were singing like
ceasefire Christmas carols in front of
the Holland Tunnel they blocking a
Holland Tunnel first of all Palestinians
and anybody taking up the Palestinian
cause the last people you want
supporting you are white liberals they
are going to ruin this [__] for you that
is a fact I'm telling you you they lost
pretty much everybody who drives a car
in New York yesterday yep literally
every everybody who couldn't get on to
the subway everybody who could sorry
everybody couldn't get on to the bridge
or the tunnel they they're gone the next
thing they going to tell you put a
colored square up on your Instagram it's
a rap after that one look at this is
singing ceasefire Christmas C you took
this I this is my video TMZ TMZ shy I've
been humming this
TB I mean the
harmony that sh goes though Kanye could
[__] don't want to see fire so they
can keep
singing Whatever prolongs this
song I mean that's SL that's actually a
pretty
good I mean what do you think
D that that was pretty good that pretty
good you got to give it to them what's
crazy is some of those liberal whites
are
like hang glider now
gler you can't do the Palestinian remix
you got you got to do the Hamas remix
that's on the other side of the tunnel
yeah they're going he
glider they're singing into each other
if you stand in the middle of that
tunnel it's so beautiful it's just two
two choirs going at each other in the
middle that's really what's going to
stop this
war cuz America's just going to Nuke the
whole area so we get to stop hearing
these [__] songs on our tunnels that
we need to go into also uh another thing
Palestinian protest don't be near a
tunnel okay protest a bridge but you
don't want to protest tunnel system cuz
it looks like you're doing
reconnaissance okay it looks like you
really like what we got going on in that
Holland Tunnel and you're like I think
we need I think we need a little bit
more structural Integrity okay Jewish
tunnels Jewish tunnels Jewish tunnels yo
those Jewish tunnels are
s h tunnels Jewish tunnel tunnel say
again did you see the Jewish tunnels
yeah but they're all Filthy it's
disgusting wait what the [__] you think
you saw this guy I said this to you
yesterday just the most New York [__]
this guy trying to get through the
tunnel while all the people are singing
oh see and this is where the
intersection between like free Palestine
and then BLM like connects this they
don't they don't know what to do here we
goed idiots can't do that that's against
the
law yeah black people call out the law
he just start shoving
people fire
now fire cease fire
now and they literally just let him go
through they're just like all right all
right he's black it's okay he's
black oh fire that's no time this all I
know I'm not a New York CU I just would
have turned around i' been like all
right fine you would have you would
course I would definitely get caught on
camera 4K fighting the you know gay dude
there's no New Yorker that's not going
right through that [__] line three
honks followed by you can just drive
through let let's just be Al tell me
this right now is there a single New
Yorker that is letting a group of
pink-haired lesbians stop them from
getting on the Williamsburg Bridge or
the Brooklyn Bridge absolutely not I'm
surprised he ain't hit him I would have
just that slow just slow like if I hit
you at five I've hit a friend before so
you about that
like wait you hit a FR in your car yeah
remember I told this story yeah he
talked about on patreon I think yeah oh
I was
patreon what happened he tossed me like
we were rough housing outside the club
and then he like tossed me almost to the
other side of the street and I slid and
[__] up my whole fit and I was with
the girl time and he's a big dude so you
had to get that get back they had to get
the get back you hit him with the front
or the back like the little side just
tapped him you programmed the test so
it's like I was going you know this was
years ago oh my God this is bad this is
a public not that crazy yo I was 19 at
the time I was in there with a fake ID
um that makes it better so yeah so I was
just saying bye to everybody and he was
was right there and so by accident I
gave him a little bump on my way off by
accident by accident sounds fun yeah
that's not that crazy bro if the legs
don't fly in the air I think you're good
I think I read over his toes if his
shoes stay on it's I think his to his
toes hurt no more few weeks but there
was a ceasefire there was you know
that's good what's up guys a few new
shows were announced for the life tour
this week in Boston we added a third
show uh we added a fourth show in San
Francisco we added a second show in
Phoenix and also we are coming to Austin
to play The Arena down there the Moody
Center go get those tickets right now D
andrews.com more cities more shows are
available on the website as well go
there check it out thank you guys so
much I'll see you there peace anyway
anybody else that we saw on this list
that's copper Fields oh yeah we're going
to get to the Jewish tunnels in a second
that's a pretty good tunnel but like the
the Copperfield is on it who else is on
it um Hawking I guess was on it because
Epstein heard there was a rumor that
Hawking was involved in an underage orgy
and then he was paying people to
discredit the rumor so that's why
Hawking was brought into it um and then
besides that it's like prince Andrew and
RFK RFK being there is wild I mean I had
to joke in the in the monologue but like
RFK being there is wild mhm it's uh it's
interesting there wasn't enough bangers
on the on the list and and I think
they're waiting for the second drop
apparently there's going to be a bunch
more yeah yeah and one rumor is and of
course this is going to end up not being
true and it's going to be boring like
this but uh that there's uh sex tapes I
want to see the sex tape so bad bro bro
no no you don't 100% kids yeah it's rape
you don't Dam we keeping that in keep
keeping that in we keep that in forgot
that I forgot that part can I be honest
with you before he said that I was about
to say that
I forgot the kid second you said the
second you said his kids I was like oh
this guy crazy this guy absolutely CRA
why you say that before I in my thing I
forgot Mar play the
video I forgot the bad part I thought it
was just him banging Chicks n you wanted
to see Bill Clinton pecker bro that's I
do that's the thing I want to see Bill
Clinton's stroke game but not if it's
with kids see before the kid you could
you can have no kids stop it what do you
mean you can't as long as there's no
kids I don't want to see that this [__]
if it's him with another cons said you
want to see it you [__] creep I'm not
you don't know which one I was talking
about which one were you talking about
the one with him and a
23-year-old come on bro Bill Clinton
Bill Clinton not doing that old nonsense
he not deal with these geriatric [__]
knees all crunchy he yo Clinton Clinton
likes him young yeah that's a wild
that's a wild barar what does that mean
though yeah cuz he's how old is he at
this how much I like Bill Clinton I'm
like that's young really 30 is Young for
Bill Clinton yeah yeah bro Clinton might
be the most likable human of all time
yeah he's out just so many bodies
connected with him and for some reason
my brain is still trying to be like yeah
but he ain't really he ain't really do
nothing crazy this how much everyone
loves Clinton is that like he does a
bunch of [__] up [__] everyone's like
yo [__]
Hillary Clinton Clinton she's holding
him back Clinton got the accusations
right he got underage yeah you can't say
too loud he got the sloppy to the oval
he got the island accusations he got a
picture of him in Epstein's house a
painting right what he does have one
doesn't he that it was George Bush and
him he has one had that of Epstein has
so he's intimately involved in
this but bring up that saxophone my dude
and I still hate Hillary Moore yeah it's
not w wow and I'll be bringing up [__]
that I don't even know like I'll be like
Libya I don't know where that is cuz
Libya yeah what is Libya it's like the
email what about Libya [__] email
this [__] with her server Pizza gate
Pizza yeah from I was remember there was
a uh There Was You Know The Daily Show
there was the nightly show remember the
the so basically there was the nightly
show that would come on after The Daily
Show and uh I remember I was going to do
like a audition for one of the
correspondents or some [__] they brought
me in there and I was just you know it's
a liberal ass show but I was like just
running a monk I was like yeah [__]
Hillary and then they're like yeah but
why don't you like Hillary and I was
like
Libya and I said that in front of a
studio audience and three other people
and I looked at this bitch's face I was
like you better not ask me what the [__]
lib is my information was done after the
word Libya do y'all even know what
happened in Libya
Benghazi that's a nice little buz
anything else don't ask son we got Buzz
words for yeah sudden the email for days
house was burned down yeah n the emails
bro yeah the emails where are the emails
come on yep and she hid the fact that
bill was even though he didn't do that
come on how dare why would you hide the
fact that your husband's a rapist even
though he didn't do it you got to hold
it down even though your husband ain't
do it you still got to hold it down bro
yeah that's kind respect r or die come
on man [__] Hillary free
Bill yo free Bill he's free I think but
free him even more apparently he's
hiding out in Mexico right now is he
really mhm where in
Mexico um they need to secure the Border
bro there's too many Americans that are
going down to Mexico fleeing away if I'm
Mexico I'd be like yo we don't want your
pedophiles [__] don't send them over
here they gotta they got to lock up the
Border no we you're [__] disgusting
what I'm trying you're [__]
disgusting we're not sending our best we
should send you we not sending our I
want to see that underage por video I
can't wait I didn't say that you did say
that like I can't wait for those videos
to drop I did not say that [__] gross
dude I'm saying dude we're not sending
our best we're sending bad home braiders
town of Mexico G stop it they got to
secure the yo stop it dude I see what
you're trying to do I
see Yo play that [__] again play that
[__] again now we don't have it's a
replay again when if we is a replay when
we do the edit for we don't have that
feature I want to see the sex tape so
bad bro bro he was so
hyp in his thighs I forgot the bad part
nah bro you need to stop mark need a
[__] C that [__] out this is serious
bro we're not talking about Steven Hain
anymore okay are y'all in the New
Tropics y'all didn't even get me a new
Tropic no this is
urbate
oh yo Shifty Shifty don't laugh at al
man let's a cultur individual bro let
him live I get up on white [__] like
that's 5 years old and now it's like oh
this is a [__] yeah no we're on this
other one yeah we're on this I almost
made fun of you for the same boots I
complimented yesterday I had to stop
myself I literally like the boots but I
had something lined up and I was like Ah
that's funy respected it though if the
joke SL n it wasn't no joke no I I'll
wait for brilliant IDI it's
no you can go to priz pick.com use the
promo code Schultz SZ you're going to
get 100% deposit match up to
$100 think about that okay you put in a
100 they're match with 100 then you go
get your prize pick on make sure you go
to prize.com use that promo Cod Schultz
let's get back to the show